Hello, and welcome to another episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be continuing our exploration into
the Rust programming language. Now before we do
that, I just wanna take ten seconds to
say thank you to my employer. I work
for a company called Equinix Metal, and we
are a bare metal cloud company. If you
wanna check out Equinix Metal, there is $50
coupon for anyone that wants it. It is
Rawkode dash live.
And that's actually around one hundred hours of
bare metal compute time. So please enjoy.
Today, I am joined by
Jane Leslie. Hello, Jane. How are you? I'm
good.
So you are the organizer
of the awesome Rust Mentor Project and the
lead of the Rust Error Handling Working Group.
Yeah.
Do you want to give us a little
bit more information on you? And then maybe
we'll talk about those two projects as well.
Sure. Yeah. I've been programming with Rust for,
like,
two it's two or three years now. I
think it's been almost
three years now.
And I, you know, I got real into
error handling
because of, like, this library that I wrote
that I want to open source. And I
was I was kind of unhappy with the
error handling approach and just tried to fix
it and ended up realizing that it was,
like, ecosystem wide problems. And now I'm, like,
you know, leading the project group, trying to
fix the annoyances that that still
haunt that project.
And so,
yeah, I'm really into Rust
and
excited to help out.
Awesome.
And what about the awesome Rust mentors project?
Do wanna tell us a little bit about
that? Yeah. So that's just it's like a
list of people who are interested in mentoring
anyone who's interested in learning Rust.
So there's like it's just got a bunch
of people, their contact info,
kind of like the domains
of Rust that they're interested in, like, they're
interested in, like, async a wait, CLI applications,
etcetera etcetera,
and maybe some, like, background resources, so, like,
links to their blog and whatnot.
If you're, like, learning Rust and you, like,
just wanna kinda, like, get connected with the
community, I think it's a really good way
to, like, get to know people, especially, like,
some of the friendlier people in the community
are I think are I may be biased,
but I think these are the, you know,
the the good people.
And a lot of them are obviously or
my friends, probably unsurprisingly.
Though I do have lots of friends across
the Rust community because, like, you know, that's
where I hang out nowadays.
So
Yeah. I've gotta say as someone relatively new,
the Rust community has been extremely welcoming and
very helpful with all their content and the
conferences and the talks and example repositories.
Like, it's just a very welcoming place to
be. Yes.
For anyone who's not familiar, you can find
the awesome Rust mentors project on GitHub.
And it's got a list of of mentors.
So if you are familiar with Rust and
competent with Rust, feel free to send a
pull request and get yourself added to this
and help people out. Yes. Yes. We could
always use more mentors. So please.
Awesome.
So we have a couple of comments already.
Woo, Jane. There you go.
We got another woo hoo with a little
crab
and we got some good vibes coming from
cute daily. So thank you. If you have
any comments or questions as we kind of
work along our exercise today, just drop them
in the chat and we'll do our best
to handle them as well.
So today's plan
is a big one. Now we have already
had two episodes. My dog is going crazy.
I don't know if you can hear that.
There we go.
So we've already had two episodes and we
really took a look at the syntax of
Rust and
explored, you know, string types, numeric types. We
take a little bit of look at struts,
a little bit of error handling. But we
haven't actually written any Rust to actually compile
as a real application. And that's what we're
gonna explore today.
And we have a couple of potential sample
applications that we're gonna try and work through
to giving
on time constraints and how quickly we move.
But we have to start with other worlds.
I think that's everybody's foray into a new
language, so we just do that. And really,
it's not just about the print line statement
of the whole world, but the cargo command
to create the project, etcetera, and the tooling
that we use to build that.
The second idea will be that we try
to work with an anagram finder. I have
a very large file in my directory here
with all the English words in it. So
we'll see if we can write something that
can find potential anagram information.
And then a very contrived calculator which will
allow us to use English input as well
as numeric input. And hopefully, these three examples
will just allow us to explore some of
the
idiomatic Rust things that we need to learn
and the tooling to be able to work
with Rust on a daily basis.
You happy with that? Yes.
Sounds good. Alright. So as far as the
hello world goes, this is what everyone usually
does when they when they wanna learn a
new programming language. So,
I mean, I could just create a Rust
file, inject the code, and use
Rusty or Cargo Run or one of these
things. But if I was going to do
this as a real application, what would be
the first step for you as a as
a Rust developer?
For me, it's just like, you know, you
immediately go Cargo new and dash dash lib.
I I pretty much always do lib
because I like to when I'm writing even
if I'm writing a binary, I like to
split it into two so I can do
doc tests and stuff.
And then just whatever you're gonna name the
project.
So
and it's it cheats because the the default
generation is literally a hello world program, so
you're done. So you hit enter and you're
done.
Alright.
I'm curious about that lip thing then that
you mentioned. Mhmm.
What does that what do we do when
we tell cargo that dash dash lib? What's
different from maybe a normal application?
So with dash dash lib,
it changes slightly the, like, the the project
it generates. It generates a lib dot r
s instead of a main dot r s.
And
it
doesn't I think it specifically generates a slightly
different gitignore file
because with, like, with the bins, you want
to usually commit the cargo dot lock file.
But with libs, you generally don't want to
commit the cargo dot lock file. So, actually,
we should probably delete that. That's a good
point because we are actually creating a binary.
Okay.
So we do wanna commit the cargo dot
lock. But other than that, it's it's pretty
much generating the same files as far as
I know. Like, it's gonna create a cargo
dot toml, has, you know, whatever name you
gave it and just the defaults
whatever is, like, the newest stuff. So it
always put 02/2018 edition
for a new project now. And then probably
in two years, it'll say 02/2021.
And
I think that is it. I guess it
does generate a target directory, which
is fine. Surprising,
but not weird.
So with regards to this edition, and that's
not actually something I think I've asked any
of the previous guests. But what is significant
about the 2018?
So
one of the the cool things that Rust
does is we we allow breaking changes in
the language,
and we do so in kind of a
structured manner that allows you to, like, interoperate
between different edition, like like, libraries written on
different editions with the same compiler.
And so when you enable the 02/2018
edition, it's essentially a set of features that
are not backwards compatible. Like, a lot of
features and a lot of different, like, settings
on, like, which warnings are, like, errors versus
warnings
become activated when you turn on this edition
equals twenty eighteen.
And so, like, the compiler has, like, all
of these, like, switching logic on, like, if
it's if you're currently compiling a twenty eighteen
crate, you're gonna use these rules. And if
you're not, you're gonna be, like, twenty fifteen
and using these rules, and soon there'll be
a twenty twenty one, which have a whole
new set of rules added on.
There are some restrictions, like, the standard library
is not allowed to do breaking changes because
it's linked to both versions.
So it has to be API
compatible with two with old code and new
code. But the language itself is allowed to,
like, introduce new keywords and everything.
Alright. Awesome.
Alright. So let's take a look at our
lepto r s end.
It looks like we've just got some test
test configuration.
Yes. So I could delete all that?
Yeah. I mean, it's I I think it's,
like, maybe it's
it's okay to leave it or to delete
it whether or not it depends on if
you're plant you're gonna, like, write lots of
little tests while you're going, which is kinda,
you know, on dev style type thing. If
you prefer to just, like,
do lots of testing or upfront or you
prefer to just, like, kind of
test it in the by running it, you
know. Yeah. Maybe we should I
was just gonna say maybe we should write
a small test or under her little world
application, you know, just to to explore that
concept. So
does Rust use a main function, like like
go?
Yes. It's main and then the the signature
is basically
no arguments and then it returns a termination
type. Termination is a trait that just says,
like, I can give you an exit code.
And right now, it's unstable, so you can't
implement termination on your own types without going
to the nightly compiler,
and I think, like, maybe enabling some features.
But there are a couple of types that
are stable that do implement termination. So you
can use results and you can use a
unit type, is, like, no return type. It's
implicitly a unit.
And both of those will, like,
do the, like, error reporting if there's an
error or just, like, exit status or whatever.
Okay. So to to make sure I understood
that,
this is what you mean by the unit
or no return type and that implements that
termination tree?
Yes. And so if you leave this as
is, it will compile because that is type
checking because, like, you could change main to
put, like, a return type and have that
be e like, returns unit.
And, like, this is equivalent.
Like, I think that, like, Rust syntax sugar
is
a way of that. But, like, functionally, it's
as if it were there all the time.
Whenever you don't have a return type on
a function, it's returning unit.
Oh, okay.
And then we can do print.
Oh,
hello.
Will this compile?
Yeah. I believe so. It should compile.
Well, it won't compile because it's in a
it's a a lib dot r s file.
So you're gonna need to make a new
main dot r s. Or it I mean,
it would compile
because you just have hello world colon colon
main as like a library function.
It just wouldn't run because it's not it's
not a pin. So you need to, like,
make a main file.
Alright. Alright. Okay.
But we have a main to r s
as well and this is a special file.
Yes. And so then if you put an
f n main here,
it's going to
be much happier. And then you could, for
example, you could just call hello underscore world
colon colon main.
That?
And yeah. And that this should compile and
run.
Why
is it upset?
Oh, this is not yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
So that just means I had help. Right?
Exactly.
If I leave the semicolon off, that's what
count as an expression and it would return
whatever this function returns. And it's that's a
unit and it would still work. Yes.
Okay. So I
know this is a contrived or simple hello
world application, but let's assume this application is
gonna make us a million dollars. Like, how
do I build it? How do I run
it? And how do I do the tests?
What will we do? So cargo build is
high oh, so you can do cargo check.
Let's start with cargo check.
So cargo check is essentially checking that it
compiles, but not generating any artifacts. So it
does all the type checking, but not any
of, like, the I think, linking or whatever.
And then cargo build
is what actually makes your artifacts.
And so this is, you know, obviously, it's
gonna take a bit longer.
And then cargo run is what runs the
main.
And so this should give us hello world,
and then cargo test is
how you would run the tests.
Nice.
All pretty self explanatory there.
Okay.
Let's
make this a little bit more interesting then.
So
what if I want to be able to
tweak this to take a name and pass
that n instead of world?
Okay.
So you would
there's a lot of ways you could do
it. So let's start with the simplest one
and let's just use a string. So
just let's say name and then colon and
then the type which would be ampersand s
t r.
And then in this one, you're gonna just
replace that with a formatting specifier, I think,
is what it's called technically. Yes. And then
comma and name.
And that will do, you know, your whole
string interpolation print f style thingy and inserts
that and runs the display trait
and gets that done.
Of course. And now this takes an argument.
So I mean, I could just cheat and
pass this in like this for now. Right?
Yes.
Okay. So if I run do I need
to always do a build or cargo or
cargo run did that for me? Cargo run
will always do the the the build
as a prerequisite. Yes.
Okay. So
let's I'm gonna just make this as as
contrived as possible now. So
I'm gonna write a test case here. So
is
is that at is that mandatory or can
I just put anything here?
You can put any
any test name. Yeah. Any name. It'll just
be the name of the test. Yeah.
Okay. And then if I
I'm gonna break all my code now completely.
But let's say I want to call main
with no parameters
and then
assert that I get back hello world.
I know we'll fail right now.
So this shouldn't compile.
Because of the
the type mismatch here? Or Yes. Exactly. Yeah.
It's it's expecting a an argument and it's
not getting any.
Yeah. I'm I'm gonna pretend we never made
that change for a moment. So Okay.
Because I had my alright. Okay. And so
also, this is search. Well, it's still not
compile because the the print line is a
side effect, not a return type.
Yeah. Okay.
K.
Oh, it doesn't like that. Yes. And so
that won't compile because
so when you put the str as an
argument,
it gets
some there's some syntax sugar applied. It's called
the lifetime elision rules.
And this can still apply in return arguments,
but it there there are, like, certain rules
that have to be satisfied. Specifically, you need
to have,
like, a a self argument
in order to in order to align lifetimes
in the return arguments.
Or it might be if you only have
one argument. It might I think it might
align the lifetime in that case too.
But because you have no arg input arguments,
it's go it doesn't have anything to get
the lifetime from of this string. This this
borrow is like this reference has to be
constrained to some, like, dirt this, like, some
scope in the program, essentially,
where, it thinks that that that string would
be valid
and or that reference would be valid. And
so
in this case,
because we're not actually borrowing any existing reference,
the thing we're trying to say is, like,
this is just a static reference. It's a
reference to, like, a piece of data that
is just
linked into a specific part part of the
binary, and it just lives there forever. It
exists for the duration of the program. And
so we have to manually write in tick
static after the ampersand, and that just says,
you know, this is a string that always
exists.
And then it won't have to, you know,
be derived from some input lifetime,
which is what you normally do. Like, lifetime
parameters are always just, like, relations. Like, is
this something that comes from this other thing?
Okay.
That's a really good explanation. I have I
have not really understood that previously before and
that kinda made a lot more sense to
me, so thanks.
No. I'm thinking because we're gonna be allowing
this world to be interpolated later, should we
just go ahead and make this
uppercase string?
Or we just don't put that as an
So we're not gonna be able yeah. You're
right. We're not gonna be able to add
anything in to the string
if we use a static string because, like,
it's a static piece of memory that we're
not supposed to modify.
And so yes.
Oh, so
They're happy? No. It's not happy.
Expecting a function Super.
Oh. Oh, yeah. Because this is a the
one module.
Yes.
Yeah. Okay.
Superman. That's
no happier.
Now let's remove
this. So this doesn't take a parameter anymore,
but it's actually not gonna do anything.
So let's just make this past roughly to
where we had it.
And then we can do a return.
And you're probably gonna need a just an
empty format string that has like a single
Alright.
Cool. Okay.
Now let's go back and see if our
cargo run works, which it does. And our
cargo test, which should.
And now we wanna make this our $2,000,000
application, which means parameter.
I
I still really struggle with when to use
an uppercase string and when to use this
as
ampersand string. If we're gonna be reading
m poo and the previous function, would that
mean I pass it through as an uppercase
string because it's dynamic? Is that like a
good heuristic?
The the question is if you're gonna modify
the the piece of data that, like, is
the input string.
So in this case,
we could do that.
We could, like, basically, like, expect them to
give us a string and then, like, they
are giving us the name and we're going
to prepend
hello on it.
And that would work, so you could.
I think it makes a bit more sense
to
expect
just a a stir because then we can,
like, we can make our own starting string
and then we can just use the plus
operator, which can catenate strings,
and it'll be a bit simpler.
Okay. Cool. So
assuming we were doing TDD and we were
doing this,
the test case first. So we've got users
world as default, but we also want to
accept
first accept the name,
means we're gonna do
pivot, and we expect pivot here.
And we're in a predicament now where
we need to handle
both of these cases where we have an
a parameter and we don't have a parameter.
What is the idiomatic Rust way of handling
that?
So this is one this is one of
those things where Rust isn't, like,
super opinionated,
I would say. And so there's a lot
of ways to handle,
like,
overloads,
essentially.
And
you can like, you could just have multiple
functions. You could have, like, multiple main like,
main and then main with arg or something
is one way to do it. You could
define a trait that has an associated type,
which is, like, the input and then, like,
do some type system shenanigans, but that's probably,
like, way way too much. And I'm not
even sure you could get, like, a nice
to use API out of that in this
case.
In this I I would recommend for the
for just this simple example where it's just,
like, a single argument
to do an into an input into
option.
So
what you can do is
instead of ampersand str, right, you do
input into
and then inside of the per type parameter
for into, it's option ampersand stir.
And so what that's gonna let us do
is either pass
an option
or pass
just the stir itself.
And so it'll kinda get so you would
have to change the interface on, like, number
nine, like, line nine. Just put a none
inside of the main.
But other than that, we can make this
work where you're passing none or you're passing
in David.
It's kinda like that's the way that I
like to do this exam exact example. And
so instead of option, it's impull into option.
Like let me see if I can type.
Oh, I cannot type.
Like that?
The into is a is, like, around the
option. Like, it's,
like, capital I into
and then open angle bracket
and then
close angle bracket. Yes.
Does this not like the what's this saying
on the the the ampersand?
Lifetime.
Really?
Sure.
Yeah. Oh, that's it.
Okay.
I
have no idea.
And so the way this so so
oh, you've not you've not been introduced? Okay.
So in Rust, there are three ways
to specify
generic
types
in functions.
So let let's do main two and main
three, just, like, copy this function, and we'll
do all three versions. That's cool. Okay.
So
the first one is the is the into
option.
Now
change the input into in both of these
to just t.
To just what? Sorry? To just t.
Like, just the capital t.
Like, the entire type should just be t.
Like, no option, no ampersands there. Just
And do that on the second one as
well.
And then on both of those, main two
and main three, we have to add a
lifetime parameter. So, basically, we have to declare
the type that is generic. Right? So it's
like, before the open parenthesis, you're gonna do
an open angle bracket, capital t, close angle
bracket.
No. No. No. Out right after the function
name.
And then
in the first one,
we're gonna do a a colon directly after
the t inside of the angle bracket.
In in the no. In the in
the type
declaration,
in the, like, the type parameter. Yeah. And
then we're gonna put the same into option
ampersands turn, but we're not gonna put impl.
And so this is saying we are declaring
a generic type, which is basically it's like
a variable for types. Right? It's like if
if,
you know, your name is a variable for
strings at runtime, t is a variable for
types that compile time where it could be
a string or it could be an option
string, etcetera, etcetera.
And then in the
the third one, in main three, we're gonna
go after the return type, and we're gonna
put a new line.
And we're gonna type where
and then new line
and then t colon and then the same
thing.
There you go. So
all three of these are the same thing.
There is one very slight difference
in that you cannot
manually
specify the type of the first one. The
first one is like a is like a
a more restrictive anonymous
type parameter,
so you can't do, like, turbo fish. So,
like, normally, in in main, you could type,
like, super main colon colon open angle bracket
and then the actual type, and then it
would type check. It would not infer the
type.
But
with the the first one, because it's an
impl, that's disabled.
But the second two, because they are actually
declared in the the type parameter list, then
you can actually turbo fish and specify what
you think the type should be.
But in all these cases, we're saying there
is going to be like, we accept multiple
different types of types. So it's gonna it's
gonna generate a compile time multiple versions of
this function that accepts different types.
And as long as it has an into
option,
it'll work. And an into option star, it
will work. And right now,
all these like, we're not actually like, the
tests are gonna fail because we haven't actually
started using that type parameter correctly yet, but,
like, we can then,
like,
implement like, to call the into trait to
get an option, and then we can check
it option, see if we have a name,
and then handle the default case and do
everything that our tests kinda expect us to
do.
Okay. Awesome.
So just to make sure I understood this
correctly.
These are two different approaches for providing a
function that takes a generic type when they
were given a little bit of guidance to
what we think that generic type is gonna
be. I'm assuming with this one, can I
have multiple implementations of this where the WER
type is different without changing the name?
No. Yeah. Rust doesn't do overloads like that.
That that's like what you're what you're talking
about is called specialization.
And
I'm not sure specialization will be usable directly
on functions. I think it it'll have to
be done via traits.
I'm not sure. It's like the feature doesn't
exist yet. So it's like
Okay.
I'm I'm just thinking, I guess. Let this
list to me. I had a lot of
a Alexa experience. This feels like a guard
where we're saying we expect this type of
function to be exist here. But I would
normally expect that to be over loadable, but
It's not.
That that's fine. So let's comment this one
out just now.
This one, I understand.
You explained that very well. And I wanna
do one more thing with this one before
we move on. Who'd have thought we'd spend
so much time on Hello World? Like
but it's it's really a lot of noise
coming from here, so I really appreciate that.
Now I wanna talk about the semantic differences
between
these. Now my understanding of Rust, I think,
is this this this is just an online
type where we're saying that something that implements
the n two trait, so it can automatically
do the conversion for us. Mhmm. Whereas if
we do this option,
we would expect the option to be passed
in, meaning we would call some
David.
Mean Exactly. Is that right? Okay. Yes.
Cool.
Yeah. I I've never seen this in line
implementation
of a tree kind of type parameter. That's
pretty nifty.
Yeah. It comes in handy sometimes. Like,
I I I tend to prefer wearer bounds
as like a rule just because, like, I
think they look a lot nicer and they're
easier to read.
But
especially for, like, really short traits,
I find it can be really nice and
definitely and even more readable than whereabouts. Just
do, like, import as ref
u h or something like that, you know.
And if you're just it's just gonna be,
like, very short, like, 10 characters or less
trait name.
It fits well into a type position.
Alright. Awesome. Okay. I'll leave that comment today
because when I push this code up and
added to the show notes, I think those
examples might be useful for for other people.
So
let's make our test pass and then we'll
move on to the next example. So
right now, this is still gonna fail, but
we could well, let's see what happens when
it fails.
Your main has to put none in it.
Of course. Okay.
Also, my app my application didn't compile, so
the test didn't run? Mhmm. Is that what
alright. Okay. So the default work, we don't
have the names. And then we update our
code,
like, good TDD developers,
and we say, okay. This is the
name.
And that won't work. But yeah. So that's,
like, the first step. Right?
And so the reason that won't work is
because
right now, the only thing the compiler knows
about that type is that it implements the
into trait.
It does not know if you can display
it. It does not know,
like, if it is already a string or
an option string. Like, it's less so it
will not let you do anything
except call into. It's literally the only thing
you can do with this type. And so
first, you have to like, before you I
would do this on, like, a line before
that so you don't get, like, some, like,
super long thing.
Just do, like, let name equal name dot
into.
And this is just gonna first invoke
that trait that we constrained the type by.
And so that now we know for sure
that name
is an option
static string.
Right?
And so you can print that, and it
will probably still not compile because I don't
think option implements display. I think it only
implements debug.
And we could unwrap it, but that would
not that would break the default case. But
but that might be, like, a fun, you
know, half next step.
Okay.
So I understood that correctly. That is just
con that's just confirms that we have an
option
string types. And we It does
the conversion and gives us the the the
type that is now, like, statically known.
K. So
would that work? No. It would work. Yeah.
That would work. But your main would still
probably not compile. No. Your main would compile.
So why are you complaining at me, Rust?
I don't know why the error is at
the bottom of the docs and not the
top.
I keep meaning to fail an issue for
that.
It takes one parameter, but two were given.
Oh. Oh. I see the string from. Yes.
So you just change it to a format.
Not not string format. Just Yeah. For yeah.
There we go. Yeah.
K.
So it should compile.
Doesn't implement display.
But
you don't you you're not using display. You're
using debug.
Oh, it just took a moment. Oh, okay.
Yeah. So that should compile, but should fail
tests.
Yes. Because we have okay. So now we
have the option type.
Yes. And so now we just wanna do
is unwrap it and provide the default case.
So we're gonna do unwrap
or unwrap underscore or
and then
world.
And so that's gonna give us I think
it needs to be lower case based on,
like, your Yeah.
Yeah.
And so that'll either give us the string
that we were passed in via the into
type, or it will give us the default
case. And that should pass through your tests.
Yay.
Nice. Okay. Cool. So
the next step would be
if we want to accept and
What kind of input you wanna accept?
Why don't we like, I don't feel we
need to go down the route of prompting
interactively.
So if if we could just make it
satisfy something like cargo run with the first
parameter and we'll just pull that out, pass
it through, and then Okay. So
the the easiest way to get the the
parameters is from stood and it's one of
the modules in this shared library,
and it provides
the args functions.
So args,
the the
fourth one in that list,
gives you an iterator type,
which is gonna iterate over all the args
in the command line.
And
the the first one should be the program
names. You're gonna want the second one. So,
like,
dot nth one
with just n t h. Oh, nth.
And then, like, let yeah. Let me pull
that. And then
you could probably just pass that straight in
and because that's that's an option as an
into option, so that works. And that'll just
if you don't give it an argument,
it will do hello world. And if you
give it an argument, it'll do hello whoever.
But we get an uppercase string instead of
Oh, okay. So then do as ref after
name.
As ref.
Oh, what do we got now?
Yes. I think we As d ref?
Does not live long enough.
Yeah. It says name does not, like, live
long enough
borrowed value.
Borrowed
value does not live long enough. There we
go.
Oh, because because
because we constrained it to a static type.
So can you go back to the live
dot r s?
And can you just instead of static,
can you can you add a just do
tick a
and then
add a a generic parameter for just the
lifetime?
So go back to the main like, the
function name and open angle brackets and then
tick a.
And let's see if that's happy. Yeah. There
we go. We're good. I don't know why
it's not able to infer a lifetime inside
of the trait the into trait. That's that's
strange.
Must be
Okay. So let's break that down as well
briefly then. So when we use the tech
static, what we're saying is this string will
live in memory for the lifetime of the
program's execution.
Yes. When we say tech a,
and this is part of the signature here
in this function, what we're saying is the
string will live long enough for this function
to run only. Is that no? No. No.
What we're saying is
the string will live for some generic lifetime.
So tick a is a generic parameter that
is like
it it's acting like generic, though it's like
not really the same thing because it has,
like, all sort of special case rules because
lifetimes are wild.
But,
essentially, it's saying, like, there is there is
some lifetime
that,
you know, that this function will accept or,
like, this will accept, like, any lifetime, really.
And
the this is specifying, you know, whatever that
specific lifetime is. Like, it's it's not the
lifetime of this function. It's the lifetime of
the data that is being passed in. It
is, like, actually,
when you pass in the data, it infers
the lifetime that that variable is associated with
from the data that it's passed in. So
now for that, like, specific piece of data
that you passed in, it's like that's what
the tick a means. It's like the string
that you're passing in in the main function
is the tick a is referring to how
long that string lives.
And the the entire like, how you use
that throughout the rest of the function definition
is basically constraining,
like, oh, however long that input string lives,
you have to make sure, like, my output
type. If I were to, like, put tick
a as like constraint on the like the
borrow of like a return type, then like
just make sure that like whatever I returned
to you doesn't live longer than that borrow
that you made
on this string in the main function
is what you're essentially saying.
Awesome.
Cool.
So the compiler works out then. Right? Yes.
Okay. We have a couple more comments there.
So Patrick says, never consider using that interesting.
That's nifty. Yep. I I thought the same.
But also followed up with, could we use
a tick underscore for the lifetime instead of
tick a? Yeah. Let's try it. Get get
rid of the the parameter, the declaration and
no. No. You did just put nothing there.
Like, get rid of the the angle brackets
altogether and just put tick underscore. And
see if that works.
No.
I can't Can
you run it in the terminal? I just
wanna see if it gives I think it
might be cutting off some of the diagnostic.
Don't
Sure.
Missing license is fire. Okay. It does not
specifically say that you're not allowed to do
interesting. Okay. Go back. Yeah. I was just
I was expecting the diagnostic to be, like,
more aware of the situation. Because a lot
of times, like, Rust actually understand like, the
compiler understands a lot more than just the
language. This is, like, if you ever watch
Esteban's talk at RustConf, he he goes into
this.
It's it's quite good talk. Highly recommend it.
Where, like, you have to understand, like, a
superset of the language
in order to, like, do good error messages.
You have to understand what people meant,
not what they said. Even if what they,
like, said is completely nonsensical in your language.
And so I would have expected in this
case for it to be like, no. You're
not allowed to put an inferred lifetime here
because of this rule and to give you,
like, a clear explanation, but it didn't. So
I was that's what I was a little
bit surprised by.
Oh, okay. Cool. Yeah. So one of the
previous guests was talking about the error messages
and the effort to enter their to the
point where I think JavaScript style async await
was actually implemented in the compiler so that
they could recommend or explain how to do
it in the Rust way, which I thought
was very clever.
Okay. So we should be we should be
done, I think, whoever
very contrived hello world. But I I think
And now we should be able to run
it. We should be able to run it
and pass in an argument and have it
do with no argument, it should do the
default.
Hello, world.
Ta da. Oh.
We covered a lot of
nice Rust things there. So that was that
was great.
Let's
move on then. Unless you think there's anything
you wanna add to this before we go
back.
Yeah. Somehow we managed to get into both
lifetimes
and all the different types of generics while
doing hello world.
Yeah. I haven't like made anyone like tune
out because it's like, I was coming here
for faces.
So No. No. No. I think that was
that was great. So
we have a letter r s. We have
something we're shipping to the library. We can
then add a main dot r s
and that just worked. So I'm happy with
that.
Let's move on to the next one then.
Okay.
With this.
Now
yeah. We did all that. Oh, we didn't
ask in line, but let's skip that. Let's
do the word one then. So let's see.
W l words.
I mean, hello world.
We could create a peg word fail here.
I'm gonna do cargo new. We'll see anagram
finder
and put up this here. I won't bother
opening a new code.
And we have our labs r s.
So if we break this problem down, what
we wanna be able to do first is
the exact same as our hello world where
we have some function
of dynamic grams, which takes
a word
of typed
string. I guess we could do that.
And we want to return
something here,
an array or a slice
of other strings.
Mhmm.
Would that be
this,
This?
No. It would be it would be around
it. So it would probably
so
this specific
signature
would probably be a little bit difficult because,
like, if we're gonna pass a slice, it
has to be, like,
reference to own data.
And if we're only passing an input as
the stir,
then it'll be a little different. Let's let's
have this function also take the dictionary
as an input.
So, like, all the words, like,
Even that, I'm not sure. I think it
might be best to just, like, return an
like, a a vec of own strings and
not deal with the lifetime
parts here. So get rid of the dictionary
argument.
Okay. So And then just the vec and
then angle bracket string.
And it should be a capital d.
Capital d. Yeah.
And then you can put to do as
the macro
in there, and it will not
give you compiler errors anymore.
Okay.
So we
also need then load dictionary.
We'll just leave, like, after now.
And let's just let's make this artificial for
the time being. So let's say it can
it
finds no anagrams.
What we're gonna do is call find anagrams
or the words
anagram.
And we should get back zero?
No. None?
We should get back
a back,
but let's just do just do vec exclamation
mark and then, like, nothing. It should yeah.
That'll work. Though I would normally do square
brackets just as, a style thing,
but I
think macro rules will accept
anything there, maybe. It depends on how you
define it. Macro rules are a little weird,
and I'm not actually that good at them.
If you wanna get into macros, you should
have Jam on next because
he's very good at macros.
Definitely.
Okay. If we I forgot the super.
And if you wanna if you don't wanna
keep remembering the super, go back real quick,
delete that super.
And then
in the top of the module,
like yeah. Just put use super colon colon
star,
and that'll just import everything
from the
above scope.
Nice.
Okay. Let's run our test.
The right directory.
Okay. Could not infer the type.
That's
interesting.
It should be all in for the type
there. This might be something to do with
how assert is implemented.
You can just I would like, just get
rid of the assert equals
and
just do, like, if
and then find anagrams equals equals
like, just, like, write basically, write out the
assert ourselves.
Or I guess it should be not equals
because we wanna
and then just panic.
And then
yeah.
I'm surprised it cannot infer the type parameter
there. I guess you could I guess it's
because
oh, I know why. It's because you can
compare types
that aren't the same. So the way that
the equal trait is defined
or the partial equal trait is defined allows
for, like,
lots it's it's a generic on the other
side, essentially. And so
the compiler isn't able to, like,
prove
that because you're doing an equality on these
two types, they should be the same type.
And so
we have to write it out by hand.
We have to, like, basically, like, define the
back.
The easiest way to do that is just
to not use the macro. And so instead
of vec exclamation park, we're gonna just do
yeah.
Oh, yeah. That works too.
Alright.
Yep. That's that's definitely that works. And then
there, we can do this the
Yep. This way.
And
and words.
See.
Test pass. Okay.
So I'm
not gonna keep adding new tests. Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I was gonna say I'll just keep adding
more assertions, but then I'll get confused. I
don't like being confused. So it can find
a
single
anagram.
I guess it doesn't really matter. It just
it finds anagrams.
Yeah. I always struggle with the naming things
more than writing the actual code sometimes.
So string
from
and these I know these aren't real, but
we'll just we'll make it past the fake
case first. So if I say find anagrams
or
David, it's gonna return
words.
Alright?
Sure.
Yeah. Why not?
I should just think of a real anagram.
Where did that pass?
One test.
Oh, yeah.
Test.
Yeah. That's better.
You know any anagrams? I can't think of
one off my head. I've got pressure. I
would just do, like, v I d d
a. Just fucking make up one. And then
you probably should lowercase the the d in
the David because we don't wanna actually and
yeah. In your name because we don't wanna
have to k.
Okay. Yeah. We're we're not using the word
fail right now, so it doesn't matter. You're
right. Good call. Okay. So now this is
gonna fail. So we need to make this
actually do something.
So
before we start doing a load dictionary, let's
just say if
word
equals
David.
A vector of
string
from
this is what pet TVD is all about.
Right?
This is this is
professional software development folks. This is what we
do. This is what we're paid for.
Exactly.
It was
they said that if you got that wrong,
I'm contriving it and still getting it wrong.
So let's see what did I do.
Find oh, I called it the wrong way
around.
Yeah. David should return. Vita.
Okay.
So one more test. I'll remember
the
annotation,
and this time but I don't need that
anymore.
We now can't take it anymore. We need
another anagram.
So let's just pick the
let's take a look at this word style.
Those are interesting words.
Emphasis and c.
That's my favorite word.
The the word two.
It's supposed to be every word in the
English language.
You know what? I'm just gonna Google it.
Like,
anagram, please.
What's
the first anagram?
Elapsed and asleep. There we go.
That's our test case. Oops.
Okay. So
we're gonna pass in asleep, and we expect
to get back our
words. We can just redefine that
as back
string
from
a lapse.
Mhmm.
And that should fail because we haven't run
any
code yet.
Okay.
So
I guess what we oh, we got some
comment. I was too busy with my fake
code there. Sorry about that. Yeah.
Race car. Good one.
That does the next the next test case.
Stop stop trying to feed palindromes into our
anagram machine. You're gonna mess it up. It's
fragile. It's a fragile baby.
Okay. So
shall we
handle the load of the dictionary?
Sure. Yeah.
Let's
so the code test, what we wanna do
is open the file
Mhmm. Split
on a new line
Mhmm. And store a set of words.
Simple. Right?
And return and probably return the set of
words.
Return
words. Okay.
So
when I can try this example, I thought
it would be good because we'd maybe have
to rely
on a third party create. I don't know
if this is all in the standard library,
I'll use your guidance here. It is it
is all in the standard library. Alright. Okay.
Well,
why don't we just artificially
contrive
magic words, a create enter a project just
so we can go over that for people?
So do you have a favorite crate?
A favorite crate?
Alright. Yeah. Let's use struct ops. Let's let's
make the interface to running this thing nice.
Like, if you need a if you need
a crate,
struct ops are great crate to just pull
in for like little
tools.
Okay. So
for anyone who's not familiar with crates.io,
it is just where you find other Rust
libraries. You can search. You can click on
it. It has a link to the repository
here if you wanna go check out the
code and a copy button for a copy
and enter our cargo dot toml.
For cargo dot toml, we just drop that
in like so, and we now have struct
available to us at our project.
Can I actually introduce another way to add
struct up to or to add dependencies?
Do you have Cargo Edit installed?
No. Is that a plugin? It it it'll
be Cargo Add is the thing. Cargo Edit
is the is the thing is the actual
tool. If you yeah. So so look up
Cargo Edit on GitHub or, like like, Google
Cargo
Edit. It should be from Killer Cup is,
I think, the author.
There we go.
And so it should just give you, like
it's probably just cargo install
cargo edit. Yeah. So run that.
And this is this is, like you know,
if you if you do Rust a lot,
you should have this installed, in my opinion,
because it's just
it's like I I I hate having to,
like, look up the version number
and be like, what exact what's the newest
version number? I go go to creates, find
the thing, copy it. It's just too much
work.
I I just wanna write cargo ad struct
top and have it find the version number,
put it in my TOML file, and be
done with it. And that's what that's what
cargo edit does. So you just you just
have to know the name of the dependency
you wanna add. And you could do, like,
cargo add struct op dash dash dev,
and it'll add it to your dev dependencies.
So it won't even, like, it'll even make
the section if you don't already have it.
It's it's very nice. Oh, nice.
Highly
recommend.
Oh, no. We are
waiting on the infamous cargo build things.
Yes.
This is
a maybe we could go to the
the hello world example. I was thinking because
I actually kinda want to introduce this for
when we were doing that example, which is
what made me think of it when you
asked for a crate. Oh, okay. So we
could change the the hello world example to
instead of using stood n to
use struct opt.
So Okay. So if I just paste this
n oh, no. It's not on my buffer
anymore. Struct op equals
star.
That works. Just
just do 0.3.
Yeah.
It
shouldn't do star usually in in Rustland. They're,
like, very, very strongly discouraged
to do.
I just copied it. Yeah. It it it'll
it'll fill in the 21 automatically.
And I don't know. Keep in red squiggles.
Maybe Rust Analyzer is just a bit confused
today. So Yeah.
I also saw when you opened Versus Code
that you're not on the current version of
Rust Analyzer. So you might wanna, like, close
it and reopen it and click the download.
But I'm not sure if you wanna, like,
wait for more things to so
so are you familiar with struct opt? I
am not. No. Okay. So it's kind of
all in the name.
You define a struct. So just like after
main or before, you know, whichever style preference.
So you just do, like, struct and whatever
you want to have, like, the type be.
I would just do, like, either options or
args, like, whichever you prefer.
Sorry. I don't understand. Oh, you need to
give it a type name because this is
like, we're defining a struct. Right? And so,
like, after the struct keyword,
you have to give it, like Oh, alright.
Okay. Okay. Fine. Whatever you're naming this type.
Hello, Prems. Perfect.
And then you're just going to push a
derive
in front of the the struct up.
So derive
and then parentheses.
We have an extra c in there. And
then I think it's struct up all lowercase
because you have to it's, like, scoped. It's
still, like, the the, like, the macro exists
in the namespace of the crate. And then
cap yeah. That one. Big,
capital s, capital o. Yep.
Oh, my computer is struggling.
Having a good time.
Yeah. I can't I can't type anymore.
Wow. That is exciting.
Maybe yep.
Yeah. We'll we'll just watch that.
Sorry.
So yeah. So I'll I'll explain what struct
opt does. So struct opt,
it generates
a and it's it's a library that's built
on top of CLAP. CLAP stands for command
line argument parser. It's like the premier
kind of
biggest,
most used argument parser library in Rust. It's
not the only one. There are lots of
other good ones. A lot of people don't
like,
a lot of people don't use clap because
it generates a lot of code. And so,
like, if you have those constraints, that's why,
like, Google wrote r h, which is kind
of like, we wanna have a struct up
that's actually good if you have, like, you
know, binary size constraints.
And so we're gonna generate efficient code, whereas
struct up and clap are kind of like,
we wanna give you every feature you could
possibly want from a command line argument parser,
whatever the cost. And I think it's usually
worth it personally, so I just use struct
up. But
there are lots of options out there. But
clap gives you the argument parser. And then
struct opt, what it does is it looks
at the definition of a structure
and infers
a lot of, like,
the what type of arguments that you would
get
in the the argument parser from the structure.
And so, like, for example, if you have
a name
and a string, right, what's what's referring right
there is that you have a an argument
where the flag is called or the name
of the argument is name
and the type that it expects to get
is a string. And so it will parse
it as a string. If you were to
put a u h there, it would only
accept numbers
and probably only numbers between zero and two
fifty six. And, like, if you passed it
like, even though the like, at the command
line, like, when it gets it out of
stood args, it's, like, actually a string.
But struct opt and clap are gonna parse
it and make sure that it, like, actually
matches the exact type you have.
And then you can put
attributes
on each argument to kind of basically, like,
add
kinda like like to invoke the functions you
would normally do when building a command line.
So if you do
before lucky number,
put a
attribute. So as hash,
yeah, opens
square bracket and then struct opt
and then parentheses
short,
comma, long.
So this is saying we wanna have a
long and short argument. So now this is
basically
turning it into, like, a flag.
So you can do dash l, I think,
would probably be what it generates
or
dash dash lucky dash
number or maybe lucky underscore number. I'm not
sure exactly
if struct up normalizes the underscores.
So this one is now an optional argument
because you've added those, whereas the name one
is a positional argument because you don't tell
struct up that it's a a flag.
And then you can also do something like
you can put string for name in option
in an option,
and struct up will automatically,
like, assume that this argument doesn't have to
be present. And so now
you can pass in you could like, with
this command line, you could pass in no
arguments and it won't give you an error.
And if you passed in one argument with
no flag, it'll know it's the name. And
if you pass in, like, a dash l,
it'll know it's the lucky number. And so
it's, like, generating all of this
just from what you put in. You can
put in a spec if you want multiple
arguments. It's like it's so intuitive and easy
to remember for me. It's like the best
thing. I fucking love it.
Okay. So let's go through the process of
removing this lane and actually
getting our struct from struct up.
What
what's the process of that? I just did,
like, options
equals,
I guess, struct up something? You know, it's
just gonna be held because this is this
derive is implementing
a trait.
And so I think it's just gonna be
hello params colon colon from underscore
arcs.
And then this will probably give you a
compiler error, but compiler error will be helpful.
So we, like, we just wanna look at
the compiler error.
And it should say
it should say that we're missing a
trait in scope because, like, you can only
use trait methods on on types if the
trait is in scope.
And so I think there is also a
struct opt trait that this thing is actually
implementing. So we we're gonna have to do,
like, a use struct opt struct opt,
probably.
Yeah. So use struct opt struct opt right
there. So copy that line near the bottom.
Just shove that in there somewhere.
Now
Yeah. Now now we just need options
dot name dot as d ref.
And then so you can do cargo
run
and then dash dash. So the dash
why does it say that's required?
Oh, because it's not an option. You have
to have so even with the flag, it
has to like, the option is is, like,
you need to specify that.
K. So we can add a cargo run
on it. So why don't we get hello
world? I noticed that I added a a
help So that's gonna that's gonna give you
the cargo because you're still in the cargo
command line. So you do a dash dash
nothing after that to say, I'm at the
this is the end of the cargo arguments,
then everything after that will be passed into
the binary you're running. And so that's how
you you get the help. And so by
just using this struct up thing, which is
relatively trivial, we now get this usage which
says, hey. You've got a positional parameter and
some optional parameters here. Mhmm.
And if you and also if you go
back, you can
you can go back to the hello world
example. You can document it. So just put
a doc comment line above the name and
it's like the
it's, like, the per the the thing that
we're gonna say hello. It's a triple forward
slash.
Triple oh, yeah. Of course.
Alright. I was in JavaScript mode, I think,
there or something. See. Or Elixir. So we
can say this is
my help.
Yep.
And that shows up
as the the org's name now says it's
mail text. And you can do the same
thing for lucky number.
And,
probably, I think you could put a doc
comment on the struct itself, and it'll probably
be, like
like, kinda like the paragraph summary at the
top of the the thing. It's
it's all very nice.
Cool. Very cool. Great.
And we have
cargo ad now. Yes.
So that is one cargo ad. It says,
okay. I want the name of a crate.
CD struck dot.
I think we already added that. Why do
I move it from the
Sure. Sure.
They're gone. And we see it's dropped out.
Alright. So it resolves the version for us.
It's added it here. Mhmm. You also said
I could do dev?
Yep.
Yes. Okay.
Okay. That's now my new favorite cargo plug
in.
Okay. That is a nice little segue there.
Although, I think my computer was a little
hot. Let's do this. I'm sorry.
Okay. So we we said we could do
this all from a standard library, but we've
now explored
the crates. So
let's get started with opening the file. I
most I don't think we'll we'll get through
this with the time remaining. So we'll just
do a couple of bits and pieces and
then we'll we'll wrap it. Okay.
So
let's do, like, just the easiest thing we
can do.
So there is a helper method in the
standard library
that
will just read a file. Right? And so
this is gonna, like, shove it all into
a string,
and it's it's, know, it's gonna make a
big allocation, and then we're gonna have to
cut it up and make a bunch more
allocations. So it's not necessarily the most efficient.
Do you wanna do it the the the
easy way or do because, like, do you
wanna move forward or you just wanna just,
like, show people how to do file IO
correctly?
Your preference.
Are we trying to it correctly? File IO.
Let's just do file IO correctly. Yeah. So
can you open the browser?
And then I want you to just type
in the the in the URL field, stood.rs/buffreader,
b u f r e a d e
r.
And so this just automatically
goes to the standard library docs and does
a search. And so now you can click
the first one, which is struct.
And so this is this is the important
type for doing IO in Rust correctly. Like,
you can open the file directly and read
from it directly,
but, like, that's gonna do a ton
of operating system, like, calls. Right? So it's
gonna be a lot slower.
And so you're always supposed to use buff
read around the file, which will, like, actually
allocate a buffer that you can read a
bunch of bytes into, and then you can
read out of that at your leisure, and
it makes it all much more efficient.
And so then
let let's just do a bit more explanation.
Then the next thing we're gonna want is,
lines, which I think is from the buff
read trait. So if you look at the
trade implementations on the sidebar,
it says buff read
down at the very bottom.
Right there. Yeah. And so if you click
on the traits, like, just click on actual
the buff read word,
it'll take us to the trait, and then
we can see the provided methods
on the sidebar.
And this lines function,
the one right above it, this is the
thing we are looking for. This is going
to return an iterator
over the lines
that splits it at the new lines, trims
the new line, and just gives us each
word of the file. And so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna open the file
with stood f s file open,
and then we're going to shove that file
inside of the buff reader so that it's
able to buffer the output. And then we're
going to call the lines method through the
buff read trait on the buff reader, and
that'll give us an iterator that we can
just do, like, a for each loop or
we can, like, do a collect or whatever
to generate our collection.
Alright. Cool. So let's
back a little bit.
So I might just copy these first two
lines. Right? Yes. Okay. So
we're gonna open our file.
Words
dot text.
Could you
I know that's this question mark here won't
work. Right? Because we don't return a result
type. Correct.
Now is that standard to do within library
functions or just the main? Like, what's the
the rule for that?
The rule for returning our result?
Or just would would you do that in
this function or would you just actually handle
this case properly? Like, what would be your
preferred approach?
So,
normally, I would propagate out the error. Like,
if if I don't like, if there's something
I know I can do in this case,
like, there's not a file,
I know that I'm gonna just return an
empty dictionary,
then that's what I would do. Like, I
would just, like, do an if let equals
the file,
and then else I would just immediately return.
Oh, sorry. Sorry.
It's instead of the, like,
if let f or not, like,
you have to do a let first because
we're gonna have to get the binding out.
So let f
equals
if let.
Okay.
The capital o,
parenthesis,
f inside the parenthesis,
and single equals,
and then delete the semicolon,
and then add up add up brackets,
and then put f in there,
then else,
and then just return,
you know, return back. Yeah. Sure. And then
a semicolon after the final one. And
yes.
Can you do control dot?
Never mind. You you already got it.
Okay. So
yeah. Okay. So I understand that I've let
we're okay. So we're basically, you know, pulling
that out, making sure that it's okay, not
an error.
Mhmm.
Else let equal tier teams slightly
proposed.
Yeah. So this is
this is something there's, like, proposals for fixing
this. And, eventually, we're gonna basically have the
inverse of an if let where there'll be,
like, a let else. So you could do
let f equals
like, let okay
f equals file open else
return,
and that'll kinda, like, you know, bring it
into the outer scope automatically. Instead, because we
don't have that, we have to, like, use
the fact that everything in Rust is an
expression.
And so this if statement, like, with all
its branches
can have a value as long as every
branch
of the
of the if
returns
the same type.
And
we cut even though we don't actually do
that, we only return the type in one
of them, we can get away with it
because of the never type in Rust. So
there is a special type in Rust that
says just, like, basically, you're never going to
execute anything after this.
And it's for things like stood exit or
a return. Like, you know when you return,
you're gone. Like, you're out of that function.
So everything after that is never gonna get
run. And so Rust uses the return type
of a of a return expression
to then know that every expression after that
isn't run. And
when it gets an error type, it will
treat it like any other type for type
checking purposes. And so even though the never
isn't a file, it's like it's file enough
for us. So it it'll type check and
just let us keep going because it knows
that it'll never actually try and exit that
else statement.
Okay.
Random thought that popped in my head when
you were kind of explaining that. We Mhmm.
We used unwrap r earlier. Is there an
error r?
It's still called unwrap.
Yeah. Option and result both use the same
kind of like Alright.
So you could do unwrap or
but
if we did that,
we would not be able to call
the return
That's why we have to use this if
let because if let is, like, the fundamental
language control flow things and so it can
do, like, all this fancy stuff of, like,
you know, exiting.
But if you do a unwrap or, it's
just an expression.
Cool.
Okay. So we've opened the file. We've returned
an empty dictionary, but it doesn't exist. We've
got our buffer there now. Going back to
this code,
I guess we want to we followed the
buffer tray. We clicked on this.
We do we want
what
are we copying now? Sorry. So as you're
basically gonna copy it I mean, it's just
the the third line, the thing after cursor.
Because instead of cursor not not lit not
the the third populated line. Sorry. I wasn't
counting the empty lines. Yeah. So but we're
not using cursor. We're using buffread. So it's
where the cursor goes, we're gonna just call
buffread.
So reader.
And, yeah, we can leave the unwrap there.
That's that's totally legit. And this is gonna
complain. It's the same thing that happened with
struct opt where you don't have the trait
and scope because that method is implemented on
the trait, not on buff reader.
And so, yeah, once you add buff read,
it will work.
And the buff read, each, like, each line
is a result because it could have, like,
had an error when it was reading the
line from the underlying file on the file
system. And so that map unwrap is just,
saying, if there are any errors here, I
just want you to panic,
which I think is fine. We we don't
have to do, like, we could we could
skip them. We do you wanna skip them
if they have errors? I don't know. Let's
just panic. It's fine. Yeah. We'll panic.
Okay. So now we have the lanes
iterator.
If we wanna convert that into a a
set, I guess. Mhmm.
Is that the hash set in Rust, isn't
it?
Yeah. Sure. We can use hash set. Is
there something else you would use? Well, we
used the back in the other the else
statement on line 10. So so I was
thinking it would just be like a back.
But then we don't get, like, the the
properties of, like, an actual set, so we
could have duplicate words. But I think it's
fine because we're, like
we already know that, you know, the words
file is, like, trusted input.
Oh, we hope.
Should be alright. Okay. So
what do we do with our lines ator
here then?
So this one's actually
this we can just use collect, which is,
like, one of the coolest
one of the cooler functions in the standard
library.
And so
collect
uses a bunch of type system awesomeness
to basically
generate the type of collection from the iterator
that you, like, you want. Like, you tell
it, like, turn the like, what type to
make from the iterator. And you can make
any type. Right? And so, like, I could
you could say collect colon colon
hash set, and it would generate a hash
set from the iterator.
Yeah. You need the the square brackets. We
don't we don't need the colon colon at
all. Right? Because we can let Rust infer
this. And so we literally just do collect.
And then you probably just you just get
rid of the return. I mean because, like,
you can have the last expression
in a function is always the return,
which is, like, what we're doing on line
eight. We're not, like, actually returning it. So
you can do that. You don't have to
call return. We've been doing that in a
lot of places, but it's entirely unnecessary. It's
like, I think you get warnings in Rust
if you do it. It's like not idiomatic.
Okay. I'll try and get that bad habit
out of me for sure.
So that's our load text. Right? That was
just using the standard library. It was pretty
simple.
Yes. Okay.
So let's see.
So here, we
want the
dictionary equals load dictionary.
Mhmm.
And then
let's
how long have we got? Okay. Like, ten
minutes. So let's iterate over the dictionary and
that's just a really simple test to see
if it's the same number if the length's
the same and we'll Mhmm. Skip the word.
If they're if they are the same,
then we'll see what we wanna do after
that. So Sure.
We have got a dictionary and then are
we doing ator?
Yeah. We're we'll definitely use the iterator interface.
Iterator is like real good. There's we can
chain a lot of functions to kinda like
build up the rules that we wanna apply
to this iterator.
Okay. So how would we add some sort
of filter on the the length of the
the two strings? So there so there is
the filter method on the iterator trait,
which takes
it as a self parameter. So it's like
a method on thing. It takes an iterator
and you and then a closure.
So filter.
It it's not let it's not completing, so
I just assumed that it was wrong.
Yeah. It should work. It should it should
still work. And then you're so you're gonna
put that and then
l
and then l dot len equals word dot
len.
It should be parentheses.
So those are methods.
Ah, okay.
And then so now we have only words
of same length.
And then
next, we need to, like, do the actual
anagram thing where we, like, make sure all
the characters are the same.
Okay. Why don't we
simplify this for the time that we have
remaining
and call this
this count anagrams?
Oh, no. Because Rust don't actually do it.
Yeah. We just count how many words have
the same length over there.
So
this is gonna return
u
u 32.
We'll return zero as the default case, and
let's just get rid of our tests.
You can probably I think you don't need
a default case because we're we have the
iterator is already, like, implicitly going to have
a default case of, like, zero length iterator.
Okay. Well
Oh, no. No. No. You can you everything
else you did was good. Oh, well, I
was gonna we we can do account if
they have the same length. And I was
like, but it's actually not gonna be difficult
to work out if it's an anagram, is
it? I mean, if we've already got the
words of the same length, we really just
wanna create a hash set of all the
letters and then just say if they're equal
to the hash set of the letters of
the other words. So we could probably just
do that. Right? Sure. Yeah. Let's do that.
That's easy enough. So let's let's do let's
write a word to
to to letters
thing
that takes a set a string.
Okay. So word
string
return. To hash set.
Hash set of Or should we hash map?
Or I think we we could just, like,
sort the characters and then say if they're
equal. Right?
Yeah. I thought if we did a hash
set, I mean, they would be the same.
But a hash set would require that the
characters are unique.
Otherwise, it would, like, deduplicate them.
So if you you'd you'd end up with
a Vita with one d.
Okay. So really what we want is word
to sorted
errors.
Here's me thinking this is a really easy
thing to do, and then I or even
turn up with an algorithm. Okay. So I
might just do, like, a vec care. I
don't I don't know if there's, like, a
way to sort
a string in place off the top of
my head.
And then I think it's just
you're gonna do word dot cares
dot collect,
and then let that equal some back
or, like, colon so you can do after
the collect
before the parentheses.
And you actually don't need the the car
there.
So colon colon
parentheses
square bracket or angle brackets
and then back and then angle brackets with
an underscore in between.
Because the it already knows the chars iterator
is a is an iterator or characters. And
so it's able to infer that inner type.
It just can't infer the collection type. And
so you can only specify the collection and
let it infer the the item from the
iterator.
And then so we do need to sort
that still.
So we'll have to do, like, a let
unsorted
equal online 23.
Okay.
So let unsorted.
Yep.
Let me look up sort
in this here and see where it lives.
I never sort things.
So it's on the slice
type.
So it should just work on back because
that d refs to slice.
And so you're just gonna call that sort.
And you're gonna have to put a mute,
a mutt after the the let or yeah.
And then
unsorted,
and then, like yeah. That does not return
the value. So it's just gonna be a
a colon afterwards, and then you have to
return unsorted.
Just
unsorted by itself.
Yeah. Remember, you're trying to get out of
that habit. No return statements. Okay.
Cool.
And then now, actually, you should be able
to get rid of the turbo fish and
collect because I think it will still be
able to infer. Let's see. It might break
because of the sort. Let's see if it
breaks. Just, like, get rid of everything. So
how do you Yeah. Yeah.
Does does it break? Yeah. It breaks because
it needs to know it needs to know
by the time it does sort.
And then the ord, it's not able to
figure it out. Okay.
Oh, well.
Okay. So now that we have a dictionary
with an iterator and a filter,
are we doing some sort of map or
iterator? Let's do let's do map
and then just
word two sorted letters. That's it. No closure.
And then just delete the parentheses and the
arguments. Like, it's literally we're just gonna pass
in the function.
And then let's before we do this, let's
make the sorted version of the input word.
So let's do, like, after dictionary, let's say,
like, let expected equal
word to sorted letter word.
And then we're gonna do
a dot filter
and disclosure.
So, like, a, you know, vertical line l
or whatever w w equals expected.
It should be assign this or just return
it?
Yes. So we can if you delete the
VAC on line 45
and then just put a collect after the
filter, it should work, I think.
Let's see what Rawkode said.
Okay. So can you just
before the map, do a
let's see if we can do, like, dot
map
and then parentheses
w.
Oh, sorry. The
and
just do ampersand star w.
Ampersand. Sorry. Not underscore.
Let's see if that works. Does that does
that what does that give us? What does
it say?
Do two stars.
And then put an ampersand before the w
and filter.
Or
this one? No. The first one.
And then
then you're gonna have to do a final
shit. See, because we're mapping it. We're we're
destroying the original word. And so we've we
we've got ourselves
we we can't do this
as, like
we can't we can't chain this the way
I wanted to. So we have we have
to do it all as, like, I think
a single filter map.
So delete everything after
the first filter of the LEN or
just, I guess, delete everything except for the
collect,
and then put dot filter map.
And then it's gonna be word, and then
yep. So we're gonna do
let
actual
equal
word two sorted letters
and an ampersand w, I think. Or we
might just be able to put w. I
think w will just work. It's already a
reference, so it'll already deref.
Yeah. So it's we still have to, like,
actually do the thing.
And then do if
actual equals expected.
Double yeah.
Then
some w.
Else,
none.
Now why is it upsetting us now?
Because we're doing okay. So instead of iter
in the first line, into iter.
You
tell me what the difference between those are?
Yes. So into iter is that, like, the
actual fundamental trait
that is implemented on all these types. Iter
is it's like a convention, like new,
where it's, like, the way to say, I
want to, like,
the type and iterate over it. And so
iter is always going to, like, intro to
like, it's going to reference the thing and
give you a borrow over references of, like,
the borrow on the container that it makes.
Whereas into iter is always going to be,
like, based on whatever type it currently is,
I am going to convert this into the
iterator that is implemented for that type. So
for a vec,
you have, like, a couple of into iter
definitions. So, like, if it's
if it's a or just the back itself,
into iter will give you the item owned.
If it's a reference to a back, it'll
give you a reference to each item. If
it's a mutable reference to a back, it'll
give you a mutable reference to each item.
So this is into iter is the thing
that the four trait work the four loop
syntax works on. So that's why you can
do something like four word in in ampersand
vec
and have it just, like, give you not,
like, destroy your vector and actually, like, iterate
over it by reference. It's because it's calling
the, like, the specific into iter implementation
for a reference to a vec.
And so in this case, we want to
do owned iteration of the back. So we
wanna keep the strings that were in the
dictionary and return those out as owned strings
to the final thing. So if we, like
if the if the dictionary were static, then
we could, like, you know, return static strs.
Or if the the dictionary's input, we could
have a borrow to the dictionary. But because
we've, like, kind of, like, constructed this as
a temporary value internally, we have to, like,
destroy it and return pieces of it, really.
Okay.
Alright. Let's
test if this works then. The test will
fail, but, I mean, we should
We might get, like, a lot of extra
anagrams if we're lucky.
But we can probably remove this truck top
that
let's see.
I'll give it a few seconds to see
if it wants to move you on by.
I guess what we can is there a
stair contains?
Or I guess I could do You could
just do a search and then
find anagram stock contains.
And it's not gonna be words. It's gonna
just be like
parentheses elapse. Like, you're not gonna be able
to do
because contains only is gonna it's gonna be
the item of the back. You're gonna, like,
look for a single item. It's you're not
gonna be able to, like, compare a
collection to a collection with the contains method.
Started to string from one. Yeah.
What have I done?
Oh. It expects a a reference to a
string. Yes. The the the borrow checking and,
like, lifetime
like, the type type rules when it comes
to references can be, like, annoying and weird.
And it's
if you're ever confused by them, I highly
recommend looking up and, like, really familiarizing yourself
with all the syntax sugar that exists in
Rust. There's this awesome website called cheats.rs,
which, like, you can bring it up right
now. I wanted to show you the section.
Sheets .rs.
And then on the behind the scenes, scroll
down. It should be on the left column.
Yeah. Sync language sugar.
So
these all of these sections are, like
they're real good things to read. If you're
not if you don't wanna read anything else
about the language, like, read these things and
you will have, like, all all that, like,
I'm just, like, peppering ampersands and stars in
there to try and, like all of that
makes sense if you've read these sections and
understand how dref works, how coercions work, how
lifetime malition works, how method resolution works. Like,
all this stuff is, like, the thing that
makes Rust, like, not
really verbose. Like, it would be way more
verbose. But, like, they can't fix everything and
so, like, not if you don't understand the
kind of things it's trying to do for
you behind the scenes, you're not able to
help it do those things for you.
Awesome. I'll definitely make my way through those.
I I don't wanna keep you too much
longer because we're kinda over where we said
we'd be. So I'll just run a test
and we'll see what happens.
Well, it did work.
It found an anagram on accident.
Well, I think it was okay with
the the sleep one worked. I think it's
just
this one found an anagram.
Yeah. Yeah. Because because it didn't expect you
to have any anagrams, but it actually does
have anagrams.
That works. We special case it anymore. There
we go. Awesome.
That was
really enlightening. I think even though the examples
are particularly trivial and contrived, like just exploring
the language and you bring in your knowledge
and sharing that there was was really really
cool. There was a lot to digest there,
and I hope that other people find that.
No. No. Don't be sorry. That was a
miss. I hope other people find that as
useful as I did. So I just wanna
say thank you for taking some time out
of your day today. No. No. But going
through that with me and, you know, hopefully,
lots of other people will find this very,
very useful. So thank And,
Mike, you're welcome. Thank you for having me
on. Like, it's it's been really fun. So
it's a good morning, you know,
with fun teaching people Rust. That's that's like
my favorite thing. I started Rust Mentors to
do this exact thing. So, like, absolutely.
My pleasure. Awesome. Well, thank you very much.
You have an awesome day and I'll see
you again soon. Okay. See you.